[Music]
hey what's up guys marcus brownlee here
from mkbhd super casual video because um
it's new year's eve obviously so kind of
a big day in the world today you might
be watching this on new year's of course
um happy new years to you then that year
went kind of fast didn't it well happy
new years if you're watching this in
2010 and happy new year's eve if you're
watching this when i uploaded in 2009
the last day of 2009 and for this video
just right here in the comment section
below
what was your favorite part of 2009 and
what are you looking forward to most in
2010 my favorite part of 2009 was
starting a youtube channel
starting a youtube channel yes my
favorite part of 2000 what i'm looking
forward to in 2010
is
is kind of reorganizing my whole setup i
have a bunch of unboxings to do with the
screencast that i'm doing so um i have a
couple of screencasts for you guys but
what i'm looking forward to most is like
totally redoing my whole setup so that's
basically it for this super short video
not really much going on just
totally different angle where you guys
are sitting right now is where monitor
is going to be anyway i have two awesome
tutorials coming up for you guys as well
as the droid heiress review so stay
tuned for that and i'll talk to you guys
in 2010
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you